okay so
i'll fair because it's because it's it's
birthday mike was telling me
uh it's my birthday and i'd really
really like
if you could get me the latest copy of
teen vogue so i'll be doing that i'll be
running out to
to walgreens after this and getting him
a copy of teen vogue uh let me read this
article this is uh
from teen vogue magazine why
sex work is real work
i i do not believe it is a right or just
that people who exchange sexual services
for money are criminalized
and i am not for what i do doctor this
is from dr
talang mufunkin
uh the government of amsterdam a city
known worldwide for its red light
district will ban the popular guided
tours through the area starting in 2020.
the ban
stems in part from complaints calling
the tours a nuisance
that lead to congestion in narrow canal
side streets
but city officials have also said that
the ban is out of respect for sex
workers it's no longer acceptable in
this age
to see sex workers as a tourist
attraction city councilor udo
[ __ ] said according to the guardian sex
work is legal in amsterdam
but it isn't in many other places though
some people are working to make it so in
south africa
where i'm based for instance sex workers
are calling for decriminalization and
legal reform
right south africa because you don't
have bigger things to worry about than
making prostitution legal
uh they argue that
sex workers are are calling for
decriminalization and illegal reform
they argue that sex work is work
as affirmed by the international labor
organization a specialized agency of the
united nations
this situation in amsterdam so the
united nations has enough money
to have an international labor
i'll say about organizat about the us is
how many times we tell the united
nations to go [ __ ] themselves
even though we give them free rent in
new york and all that [ __ ] and
and diplomatic immunity and billions of
dollars
at least you tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves uh sex work is legal in
amsterdam
uh it says here this situation in
amsterdam and the continued
criminalization of sex workers around
the world is yet another example of how
we
disregard the needs and opinions of the
people most impacted by policies
but even more so is an example of how we
misunderstand what sex work actually is
keep in mind can you at least pepper in
the occasional man
i got you okay by the way this is this
is this is teen vogue
uh i'm a doctor and an expert in sexual
health which is not a real job hold on
hold on let me see the
doctor dr mantis toboggan
let me guess dr jonah goldstein no
no dr ira rolfe you would be wrong uh
doctor
telling mofokin doctor [ __ ] uh
david
telling moffonkin 2010 position medical
doctor and deputy chairperson
sexual and reproductive justice
you would be wrong on all fronts
oh [ __ ] okay well it's laquisha
um
where was i uh so what exactly is sex
work not all sex work engages in
penetrative sex
though undeniably that is a big part of
sex work sex worker services between
consenting adults may include
companionship intimacy non-sexual role
play
okay look here's my thing
i'm not even against the whole you know
in some cases
you know women want to hold themselves
out let them i don't i really don't care
i i'm kind of still libertarian in that
way i doesn't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about
that yeah i'm not
like i'm i my whole thing is look i am a
libertarian
so i think you should be free to do what
you want and i should be free to
look at you with disdain and voice my
opinions about your disgusting
correct you know promiscuous lifestyle
um
but like they they're taking it to a
whole new level where they're like no
all seven-year-old girls should be
prostitutes
like what whoa why do we gotta take it
to that level why can't you just be
quiet that's some time my problem is
that this is not this is
teen vogue this is a magazine for
teenagers that's publishing this so it's
basically saying
hey if you're 16 or 17 and want to [ __ ]
around
now look i know in reality that teens
don't read teen vogue anymore
i know in reality the teen vogue has
become a repository for sjw writers
and [ __ ] woke feminists and
uh other kins i know that teen vogue
that's what it is but team vogue is a
magazine that
if you pull if you look at teamvote back
in the 90s you would see jonathan taylor
thomas and like whoa
look at that cutie like you know like
that's what the magazine was about it
was about you know like
oh my god look at look at the hunks on
90210
and now it's like if you want to [ __ ]
for money do it
it's a [ __ ] how is this teen vogue
oh yeah and it's like dude it's not only
that they push drugs they push oh yeah
pregnancy stuff uh it's really
really uh just disgusting you know what
they what they've done you're right it
used to be
you know oh man who's the who's the
hunkiest
guy on [ __ ] home improvement tim
allen by the way
all the all the little girls al portland
all the little girls all the little
girls find the outboard at least the
middle school i went to
all the chicks wanted to [ __ ] al borland
where did you go to [ __ ] middle
school idaho
[Laughter]
he was a sex symbol in my school him and
[ __ ] wilson
boise he's the sexiest voted sexiest man
in boise
you don't even see wilson's bottle yeah
i'd like to have al borland come over
and do my drywall
oh yeah he'd be nice i'd like him to
look around for my studs
yeah hey take it you know what we're the
only people doing al borland references
in 2019 that's how [ __ ] cutting edge
we are
yeah i like to open up my copy of tiger
beat and flick my beans
to al borland
i'm just getting a little more this i
find it interesting that as a medical
doctor i exchange payment in the form of
money
with other people to provide the time
sometimes he gets money
and then half product you see that's the
key i've said this before folks
get it half in product you can [ __ ]
cut it flip it sell it you make a lot
more money if you're willing to take
this
assume the risk and you keep a little
for daddy yeah you keep a little bit for
the
first nice saturday night out on the
town
mike's the new writer for teen vogue i
don't know what it is
no you're right though what if teen
vogue went left wing but tiger beats all
alt right now
tiger would be great why aren't there
more why isn't there a left right
paradigm in
teen child uh related [ __ ] tiger beat
just has a white family with fashion
haircuts and polo shirts
and gentlemen in their announcement
today breitbart has announced that
they've acquired tiger beat
they're just coming in like look man why
the left is trying to destroy us
who's the name of the right-wing version
of nicholas cruz the ben shapiro clone
that the kid were in front of
kyle cash kyle kashuv on the cover of
tiger beat
like a couple of buttons undone like
yeah just having a smoke
an interview with dana losch from the
nra on the inside
i find it interesting as a medical
doctor i exchange payment in the form of
money with people to provide them with
advice and treatment
for sex related problems therapy for
sexual performance counseling and
therapy for relationship problems
and treatment of sexually transmitted
okay she's not really a doctor doctor
from what i'm reading she's more one of
the therapy doctors
i do not believe it is a right or just
that people who exchange sexual services
for money
are criminalized i am not for what okay
so so you want people to be out there
just [ __ ] and sucking left and right
fine you get it do that then
but then you also want them to be able
to do it without condoms or birth
control
that way you could then go and [ __ ]
kill baby like
how how did they left from the eyes of
like the centers for example or anybody
outside
how did the left become the moral
arbiter of
anything on this planet like it's so
weird to me
how the left is the more because they're
not he's
bro [ __ ] it all right i'm always going
to say i'm going to say anything because
then alex jones will get mad at me
today online spaces that's what they're
doing they want to eat your babies and
turn them into fiber wipe
fiber optic cables so they can enslave
the
the the newer order kits i don't know
man [ __ ]
buy some uh bone broth i'm really
hurting here can i say that
harrison i'm gonna have to pay a half on
venmo it's that
sorry hang on i lost my venmo i can't
catch up
come on harrison i got a couple bucks on
me i'm just gonna have to pay you in
cash
you're gonna have to sign a slip says i
gave it to you you accept bitcoin
we're gonna have to 10.99 in this cash
too
wait for infowars cryptocurrency coming
out soon come on you're going to buy
alex coin
does the face of him angrily on the
court would have put a frog on it yeah
frog symbol it's like just a frog with
like smoking a cigarette with a boa
you know uh somebody it's so weird that
we like alex
and when we did the v the last video
that this rant about you gotta have kids
sucking [ __ ]
the um some we commented like man alex
has so many papers and somebody actually
got mad in our comments it was like
just because alex is teleprompter free
i'm like i get that
but you could have an ipad with all the
papers pulled up like you don't need to
have a desk
full of papers no uh
back to this well you know the last time
he waved an ipad or a phone around on
camera it didn't end well so
oh you're right you can't [ __ ] up if
it's paper let's just stick to the
goddamn papers this time i can remember
about porn all over the place here
and it turns out it wasn't any point he
was just visiting milo's new website
harrison give me 20 of that back uh
food's here i forgot to
i need to i got to pay the pizza guy
give me 20 of it back i'll give it to
you later you can have most of the pizza
i just want to slap you i'm gonna tip
the
i'm gonna tip the pizza guy with alpha
brain i was going to say super male
vitality but yes
hey come here kid you ever take some
alpha brain that's a
that's like a four dollar value right
there that you're eating
you're welcome none of the pizza places
in austin wanted to deliver to infowars
you're delivering more pizzas than
anybody else in town super close yes
every time they order chinese who when
the chinese guy comes up alex just
stares at him angrily
and blames him for everything play your
cards right i think i could get you a
hand job for gun over here
oh but she's so based and has a gun i'll
tell you what man she's got a face like
a snapping turtle but she's got smooth
hands
brother don't worry about it
we're never going to be invited on
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] a fake a face
a face like a snapping turtle killed me
she does have a sea turtle face
oh [ __ ] disturbing her face oh
[ __ ] someone i don't know you get teen
vogue i don't have to continue with the
stupid team
that's [ __ ] ridiculous